ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Can you
get a sense of
Google Cloud Platform
machine-learning products
in just a few minutes?
Let's find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Despite all the attention
lately, machine learning still
remains somewhat difficult to
build, maintain, and deploy.
Thankfully for you,
Google Cloud Platform
puts a lot of that
behind the scenes,
so you don't have
to worry about it.
So what does the
[? hello ?] world of ML
look like when you don't have to
write the neural nets yourself?
Simply calling the
Vision API to describe
what it finds in the picture.
As a leader in machine
learning, Google Cloud
offers several high-quality
pre-trained models via APIs
that can easily be consumed
by developers regardless
of the language they use or the
nature of their application.
Developers can invoke
the API directly or using
one of the idiomatic
client libraries
available in numerous
programming languages.
Here, we invoke the API directly
from the product description
page.
From this image, the API can
detect a broad set of labels,
provide dominant colors,
and other image properties.
It can also extract
text, identify entities,
such as landmarks, celebrities,
logos, or news events
along millions of
entities that it supports.
It can also moderate content
such as all of your app's
user-generated content.
In addition to the
Vision API, GCP
offers pre-trained
models for text
to speech, speech to text,
natural language, translate,
all via easy-to-use APIs.
Now, pre-trained models
are amazingly easy to use,
as we've seen, but they're not
trained on your setup data.
This is where a Cloud
AutoML comes in.
Cloud AutoML is here to enable
developers with limited machine
learning expertise to train
high-quality models specific
to their business
needs by leveraging
Google's state-of-the-art
transfer learning and neural
architecture search technology.
Cloud AutoML provides a simple
graphical user interface
for you to train, evaluate,
improve, and deploy models
based on your own data.
You're only a few minutes
away from your own custom
machine-learning model.
Now, the ML APIs
and Cloud AutoML
are great when you
want to use or build
upon a pre-trained model that
Google already has training
for.
But what if your
needs are beyond that?
Well, that basically requires
training your own models
with your own data sets on
your own virtual machines.
And I don't know about
you, but I don't always
have time for that, which is
why I use Cloud Deep Learning VM
Image.
These Google Compute
Engine instances
come pre-installed with the
latest versions of TensorFlow,
PyTorch, and scikit-learn.
You can also add
cloud CPU and GPU
support with a single click.
This image also comes with
the latest software drivers
and third-party dependencies,
including the latest GPU
software, and is
available using the GCP
Marketplace from the console
or using the command line.
If you'd like to get the
operations out of the way
and focus on your
models, consider
using Cloud ML Engine which
offers fully managed training
and prediction services for
developers and data scientists.
You can build your models
with multiple ML frameworks
including scikit-learn,
XGBoost, Keras, and, of course,
TensorFlow.
Cloud ML Engine trains
any model at large scale
on a managed cluster.
HyperTune is a
unique feature that
enables you to reach
better results faster
by automatically tuning
deep-learning hyperparameters.
Cloud ML Engine then offers
online predictions, adjusting
to any requests rate coming from
your ML-enabled applications
and does so through a
secure web endpoint.
Batch predictions
are also supported
for really
cost-effective inference
for asynchronous apps.
Whether you're new
to machine learning
or you're already an
expert, GCP has a variety
of tools to help you,
from pre-trained ML
models accessible
via simple API call,
to customizing
models with AutoML,
to training and serving a custom
TensorFlow model using Compute
Engine or Cloud ML Engine.
Consider taking free codelabs,
linked in the description
below, to explore
these products.
Check out the compute and
big data overview episodes.
And look forward to an upcoming
video on big data storage
and processing.
Please like, subscribe,
comment, and share.
See you soon for another
GCP Essentials video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]